you've said that this idea of soul mates
is great for your business but so like
a human being
in a partnership can't be everything is
that true I think it's unrealistic it's
a True Romance right the uh the document
of
that we keep referencing here I think
it's wonderful if you do because
sometimes now people don't get that
reference anymore
like I I talk to people in when I try to
teach negotiation to young lawyers who
come work for me I tell them to watch
the Gary Oldman scene
where he offers him the Chinese food
yeah why has that scene the one that
really because it's the best negotiating
lesson I've ever heard in my life where
where he comes in he's he he just called
the record yeah Gary Oldman plays a pimp
yes and he owns his girl is Patricia
Arquette right and Christian Slater's
character the protagonist is coming in
to tell Gary Oldman that he no longer
owns this girl Alabama
is going to be with him now
and Gary Oldman is a a amazing
performance and he's sitting in a living
room with a shotgun next to him with
armed guys around him watching
television and eating Chinese food and
he's got Chinese food laid out in front
of him and Christian Slater comes in and
he says I need to talk to you about
Alabama
and Chris and Gary Oldman says do you
want some Chinese food
and Christian Slater's sort of taken
aback by the question he says no I I
came to talk about Alabama she's with me
now she's then he proceeds to tell him
what his offer essentially is and Gary
Oldman says you know you [__] up right
in some in substance he says you know if
you'd sat down and started eating my
Chinese food I would have thought
who's this guy he didn't have a care in
the world just sitting down eating my
egg foo young but instead you tried to
be hard and now I know you're full of
[__] and so I think that scene
summarizes how in negotiation
the more you enter into it with that
like any time I deal with another lawyer
and they're like well we'll see you in
court okay
we'll see in court like empty barrels
make the most noise like you and I as
people who've been in the Jiu Jitsu
Community or been I know some dangerous
people I know FBI SWAT people I know you
know I know people that are they know
how to do things to people and they're
the calmest guys you ever meet in your
life you you scuff their sneaker they
think oh you don't worry about a minute
it's okay like they're quick to apology
like they're just chill what uh what
were we talking about
um we were talking about
um oh uh wait True Romance oh the
soulmate yeah soulmate yeah well you're
saying that this idea like what would
that film underlying there's this
current of like they were made for each
other yeah
I think there's a distinction
between the feeling that someone is your
missing puzzle piece that you're made
for this person I think what that just
means is there's a lot of overlapping
beautiful connections I love them
intellectually I love them sexually I
love them interpersonally we have some
shared history we have some shared
commonalities we were raised in the same
culture raised in the same religion like
we view we have politically similar
ideas like these are all or we have
totally opposite ones but they're
complementary like I've always joked
that like finding someone with
complementary pathologies
you know like I'm obsessively
disciplined so having a partner who's
like flexible and like spontaneous is
really good for me and and also me being
like no no come on come back we're gonna
do this now no no it's time to actually
do this now like we're good for each
other it's Barefoot in the Park you know
it's this idea of like you know the yin
and the Yang so
what I have an issue with is that the
definition of soulmate that I think is
sold to so many people now is this idea
that if your partner is disappointing to
you in any way meaning they're not the
perfect travel companion they're not the
perfect vocabulary companion they're not
the perfect roommate they're not the
perfect lover they're not the like the
odds of someone being all of those
seems crazy to me like it's
infinitesimally small and they don't
have to be everything
like I if I go to a restaurant and eat
10 courses and one of them is kind of
subpar and the other nine or the most
amazing culinary experience I've ever
had
how dare I say well that wasn't that
wasn't the right restaurant no what do
you mean like that's a great restaurant
what are you talking about like of
course there's one little thing so I
think it's impossible
to have someone never disappoint you
it's impossible to have someone who
never lets you down or doesn't say and
do the exact right thing at the exact
right time and to create the idea or
expectation in anyone that your partner
should never let you down never
disappoint you never not know what to
say yeah is I think crazy I mean I I
find for myself
when someone for example loses someone
when someone loses a family member or
pet
I I often say the same thing to the
person I'll either talk to them or send
them a text or call them and I'll say if
I wish I knew the perfect thing to say
because I would say it right now
like but but I know there isn't like I
know that you know I don't say that part
but like I know there isn't like I there
isn't a perfect thing to say like but if
there was a perfect thing to say I would
say it right now like love to me is not
that you never let this person down it's
that you never want to let this person
down you know it's Love Is A Verb you
know like it's this feeling of I I never
want to disappoint you I will disappoint
you
but I never want to disappoint you I I
will hurt you but I never want to hurt
you when I hurt you it will be my
insecurity my stupidity my Humanity
that causes me to hurt you but I will
never intentionally hurt you you know I
will betray your trust I'll never
intentionally betray your trust like I I
will by my stupidity say the wrong thing
or or loose lips say something to
someone that you didn't want me to but
it won't be intentional I will always
try to be on your team that feels to me
like a realistic thing yeah the
intention leads the way but there's some
aspect of
um like you know just like the 10 course
meal that over time there's a kind of
convergence
towards Perfection and along the way
there's the Rose Colored Glasses where
you see ever the beauty and everything
so it just it feels
um it's probably destructive just to
really internalize the idea of soulmate
because then any imperfections can
can make you doubt it can make you step
away can make you lose the connection
but it just feels like uh I don't know
it's too heavy it just feels I I feel
like when you see a couple
if it's 90 years old
and they've been together for 60 years
70 years
there is of course a temptation to think
about all the beauty that they've seen
on that journey together the children
the grandchildren maybe the great
grandchildren all the joy that they've
seen all the pain they've endured and
struggled together you know
but they've also disappointed each other
a whole bunch of times probably let each
other down they probably lie to each
other a bunch and yet and to me that is
a beautiful thing like that's what that
is not
it's great in spite of that it's great
because of that they still love each
other even though they've been so flawed
and imperfect and and they're human and
they still love each other they still
rode that thing together because the
reasons to do so were greater than the
reasons to not